هذا ومع استمرار هجوم ترامب على الادعاء
العام ربما تلجا المحكمه لاسكات الرئيس
السابق من خلال اصدار امر حضر النشر في
هذه القضيه طبعا هذه الخطوه اذا ما قررها
القاضي اخوان مارشنسي تمنع ترامب وستمنع
محاميه من التحدث عالمنا عن هذه القضيه
طبعا خارج جدران المحكمه المنع اذا ما تم
يعني ان ترامب لن يكون قادر على نشر ما
يريد على منصته للتواصل الاجتماعي التروس
التي يستخدمها للتواصل مع الملايين من
انصاره كانت ترامب استغل هذه المنصه منصه
التروس في الايام الماضيه طبعا انتقاد
لاذع للمدعي العام في منهات
والقاضيه ايضا نمرشن وحذر بما اسماه
بالموت وايضا الدمار اذا وجهت اليه تهمه
ترامب اعتبر ان امريكا في طريقها الى
الجحيم ويخطط ترامب لالقاء خطاب اذا كما
ذكر مراسلنا بعد ساعات من مثوله امام
المحكمه لكن امر حظر النشر قد يفسد هذه
الخطه في التي يقول البعض انها محاوله
لاستغلال الازمه سياسيا طبعا هذا كله بحسب
مراقبين بعض المحامين المؤيدين لامر حظر
النشر يرون ان الادعاء في القضيه ليس
مشهدا عاما في حين يرفض فريق ترامب
القانوني هذه الخطوه يعتبرها انتهاك للحق
في التعبير عن الراي